please welcome craig hoy chairman of the
scottish conservative party
good evening ladies and gentlemen on
behalf of the scottish conservative and
unionist party can i welcome you to
perth for the hustings the scottish
hustings for the conservative leadership
election over the last three weeks the
two candidates that we'll hear from this
evening have been crisscrossing the
country making their pitch to be our
next prime minister a prime minister for
every part of our united kingdom
organizing 12 hustings
organizing 12 hustings at such short
notice is a huge logistical exercise and
i would like to thank the teams at
scottish conservative central office and
cchq for their dedication and commitment
and i'd also like to thank
and to thank peter booth who's here
tonight and the national convention for
their support
but most important of all i would like
to thank you our members because tonight
is your opportunity to pose questions to
the next leader of our party
because whoever wins this election
will need our whole party to come
together
to come together behind them to beat
labour and the snp at the next general
election
and that's because we know that a
conservative government acting in the
national interest
will always be better equipped to deal
with the challenges ahead
better equipped to run britain than
labour better equipped to stand up for
scotland's vital place in our united
kingdom
but the challenges our country faces are
great a global cost of living crisis
rising inflation a slowing economy
an snp government obsessed with
constitutional division at any price
whatsoever
rebuilding our public services after the
pandemic
and russia's evil invasion of ukraine
i believe
that both of the candidates for the
leadership have the potential to steer
this country through these very
difficult times the potential to win
that election the potential to return
our party to government for another
five-year term
but before we hear from the two
candidates in the contest to become the
next leader of our party please give a
very warm welcome to our scottish party
leader douglas ross
thank you very much craig and thank you
members
this leadership election comes at a
pivotal time for our party
but also for our country
across the uk people look to our party
as the uk government
for support and for leadership in the
face of the global cost of living crisis
yet here in scotland
nicolas sturgeon and the snp are once
again attempting to divide our country
with a second independence referendum
just next year
so we all have very important choices
ahead of us
and for those of us in this room
the choice we make is not just for
ourselves but for the wider country as
well
the next leader of our party must
redefine our conservative beliefs and
values and provide answers to the
challenges our country faces
the next leader of our party must be
prepared to take decisive action the
action required to help
families and communities across the
united kingdom through this crisis
and the next leader of our party must
govern for the whole of the united
kingdom and work to build support in all
nations
of the united kingdom
and the candidate we choose as our next
leader and prime minister
must prove over the next two years
why we deserve to win the next general
election in that historic fifth term
fortunately for us both liz and rishi
are up to the challenges ahead
they have shown throughout this contest
that they have the vision and the
ambition to take our party and our
country forward
and when the contest is over
and the winning candidate is announced
they will have my support and i know the
support of everyone in the scottish
conservatives to meet those challenges
in the difficult times ahead
so thank you very much for joining us
here in perth today joining us online
and watching this scottish hustings but
one other person who i know will have
the full support of everyone in this
room is our host this evening so please
give a very warm welcome to the stb's
political editor colin mckay
good evening i am colin mckay from sdv
home of scotland's most watched tv news
program and we'll have full reports on
tonight's proceedings and we'll probably
speak to some of you afterwards to get
on the late news and certainly on the
sdv news at six tomorrow we're also live
streaming this on the sdv news website
free so welcome to viewers there too
because let's face it this is quite a
scary job interview for two people
tonight 650 of you here in perth concert
hall but then maybe not quite as scary
as a general election which is the way
we used to uh get prime ministers but
then you're making a bit of a habit of
this i see some faces in the audience
that were here three years ago at the
leadership hustlings and you gave both
the candidates quite a grilling that
night so we'll see how that goes tonight
but just let me check before we go any
further have you all got your ballot
papers here in the hall not with you but
have you all got your ballot papers
have any of you not filled them in yet
have any of you yet to vote
oh quite a lot of you that's quite
impressive that's not all newspapers
have been reporting so there's quite a
lot of you people here tonight to be
convinced by either of the candidates so
let's get on with that and give you the
chance to hear from the candidates
you'll hear from both sides over the
next half hour then you'll get the
chance to question them and i will get
the chance to question them and i'll
throw in a couple of questions from stv
viewers as well but first tonight we'll
hear from rishi sunak and his team
please welcome andrew bally
ladies and gentlemen good evening it's
so good to see so many people here
tonight
i am here to introduce to you our next
prime minister
i am here to introduce to you the person
i believe has what it takes
who i believe will be able to walk into
number 10 downing street on the 6th of
september and get to work the person i
trust to take the decisions necessary to
tackle the challenges we as a nation
face
the person who i know
is ready to lead us forward to our
historic fifth general election victory
and the person i know is ready ready to
take on nicola sturgeon ready to boot
the snp's politics of gripe and
grievance of division and hate that
we've seen outside this hall tonight
into touch
and keep our united kingdom our one
nation whole
friends i thought
long and hard about who i was going to
choose to be the next leader of the
conservative and unionist party because
honestly
we had an amazing array of talent
standing to be the next prime minister
and it made me very proud to be a
conservative
but i have stood in turn down extreme
i have stood by the side of a prime
minister when the going got tough
i've been in cabinet rooms when tough
calls have had to be made and i've seen
up close the relentless pressure a prime
minister is put under when being
expected to deliver
and so for me when it came to the crutch
when i had to choose the person i knew
could do that job better than any other
there was only one and it was rishi
sunak
i knew this because he has already
demonstrated through his actions that he
has what it takes and crucially that he
is a unionist he was the chancellor that
ensured that the furloughs team which
saved 700 000 scottish jobs applied to
the whole united kingdom here is the
chancellor that ensured that businesses
across the whole uk would benefit from
the bounce-back loans and the eat out to
help scheme that kept so many scottish
businesses afloat during the pandemic he
was the man that made sure the leveling
up fund could be accessed by scottish
local authorities that free ports would
come to scotland and that has led the
pushback against the devolve and forget
mentality that permeates whitehall
devolve and forget that's the
easy lazy approach to governing that
says scotland pass it to hollywood
friends we know what happens when that
happens we've seen it all too often
before because we've learned i'm afraid
we cannot trust the scottish national
party to act in the best interests of
the scottish people only in the
interests of the snp
only
only in the interest of the two-time
vote cover star tv personality
instagramer sometime first minister
nicholas sturgeon who is definitely
definitely not an attention seeker i'll
i will i'll give that to liz she got
that bit right
but you know what we don't beat her we
don't beat the snp we don't win the
argument we don't ensure scotland's
place at the heart of our united kingdom
by ignoring them friends i would love to
ignore the snp usually at about 12 15 on
a wednesday afternoon in the house of
commons and it would be all too easy for
us to hit mute i'm sure some in this
hall do to ignore them and their
constant sowing of division
but if we do that they win
we cannot and under rishi's leadership
we will not ignore them we will take
them on and we will win
rishi will bring to an end the days of
the snp obscuring its failures by
picking and choosing the data it
publishes rishi will ensure scottish
civil servants will also face greater
scrutiny in westminster friends rishi
will see for the first time that this
failing scottish national party
government are properly scrutinized by
the uk parliament
press friends this country is is facing
historic challenges incredible
challenges to our economy to our very
integrity
and so i am proud to stand to you
in front of a room of people who i've
stood beside in election after election
who i know fight every single day for
our party and for our country and
introduce to you a man a man i know has
what it takes who has what it takes to
tackle those challenges to get our
economy back on the firm footing to
invest in our child's future to lead us
as we lead the world and to keep our one
nation whole with scotland at its heart
and that man is my friend rishi sunak
[Applause]
[Music]
my values
traditional conservative values are
clear
hard work patriotism
fairness
a love of family
pragmatism
but also an unshakable belief that we
can build a better future
[Applause]
we need a substantial and serious leader
rishi sunak is the real deal and he has
what it takes to take the big decisions
necessary he has a proven track record
he's highly experienced he will deal
with the threat of the snp and the
nationalists head on and he will unite
our party and unite our country
please welcome rishi sunak
good evening
good evening
thank you
thank you everyone good evening it's
fantastic to be with you tonight now
look i am standing here in front of you
for one very simple reason and that's
because our country our united kingdom
did something extraordinary for my
family
it welcomed them here
as immigrants 60 years ago
and allowed them to build a better life
now i was raised with a few simple
values firstly that family means
everything to me
because we as conservative know the
bombs of family
are more important than anything
any government could ever hope to
replicate and we must never forget that
now in my family
the thing we prioritized was hard work
as the way to forge ahead
my dad was an nhs gp my mum ran the
local chemist where i grew up and i
spent all my time
working in her shop out and about
delivering prescriptions to people and
doing her books
seeing the power of that small business
to provide jobs and opportunity in our
local community
now for my parents
there was one thing that they believed
above all else
could provide a better future for their
three children and it was simple
it was through education
and that's why today i passionately
believe that the best way that we reduce
inequality in society the best way that
we spread opportunity indeed the best
way that we transform people's lives
is by ensuring that the birthright of
every child is a world-class education
and that
and that my friends when you look at
what has happened here is a lesson that
the snp government would do well to
remember
so that in a nutshell are my values
patriotism family
hard work service and i know looking at
you that those are your values too and
that is because they are conservative
values and that's why i want to be your
prime minister to put those values into
action to build a better britain and
ensure that everyone has the same
opportunities that i had
but how are we going to do that well we
need to do three things
first
we must restore trust
then we need to rebuild the economy
and we need to reunite our country
now when it comes to restoring trust for
me that starts with honesty
and as you can see in this leadership
race i have not chosen to say the things
that people may want to hear
i have said the things that i believe
they need to hear
now even though it doesn't make my life
easy it is honest and that is what
leadership is all about
but will also restore trust by
delivering on the things that matter to
people
that's why i set out a bold plan to
finally start reforming the nhs
so that we can stop talking just about
how much money we're putting into it and
more about the quality of the healthcare
we're getting out of it
and while i'm doing that i want to end
this devolve and forget mentality so i
will not be shy
about calling out the smp's record on
things like drug and alcohol abuse
because it's not good enough and the
scottish people deserve better
it's why i want to restore trust in our
rural communities by getting our trade
deals right backing food security and
supporting british farming and fisheries
it's why i want to take on this lefty
woke culture
that seems to want to cancel our history
our values and our women
and it's why i've set out a plan to
finally get to grips with illegal
migration because i stand here as a
product of our country's proud and
compassionate history of welcoming
people to our shores but it must be done
fairly and legally and when we turn on
our tv screens and see scenes of people
coming here illegally it undermines
trust in the system and that must be
fixed and with my plan i will fix it and
take back control of our borders
now when it comes to rebuilding the
economy i don't need to tell all of you
you know what the challenge is it's
inflation
and we've seen this story before
inflation is the enemy it makes everyone
poorer
it eats into people's hard-earned
savings and pensions
it pushes up mortgage rates
and at a time
when millions of people are anxious
about the cost of living this winter
politicians should be relentlessly
focused on addressing that and i'd say
that to nicola sturgeon that is the
priority not another divisive
unnecessary constitutional referendum
so
so this winter of course i will provide
the help particularly to the most
vulnerable in our society cutting v80
but going further for those groups that
need it because that is what a
compassionate conservative government
must do to protect the most vulnerable
but what i will not do
is pursue policies that risk making
inflation far worse and last far longer
especially if those policies amount to
borrowing 50 billion pounds and putting
that on the country's credit card and
then asking our kids and our grandkids
to pick up the tower
because that's not right
it's not responsible and it is certainly
not conservative
now i will deliver tax cuts and for the
first time in 16 years in this
parliament i will cut the rate of income
tax
because unlike the smp government who
have chosen to not pass that tax cut on
even though they have been given the
money to do so a conservative government
will always make sure that people's hard
work pays
but we will
we will deliver those tax cuts
responsibly by being tough on public
spending and by growing our economy
and that's why this autumn will
radically change how we tax businesses
in this country cutting taxes for those
businesses that are doing the right
thing investing to grow
innovating to create the products and
services of the future because that's
how you drive growth in a modern economy
and in scotland i want to keep investing
supporting our fantastic energy sector
making sure that we reform our financial
services regulations to keep the
scottish powerhouse of financial
services growing it's why i want to make
sure that i go further than i did as
chancellor and actually finally deliver
not one but two free ports right here in
scotland
because my friends
we have to deliver the economic growth
here we can't trust the smp to do it can
we they can't even get the ferries to
work
because in two years time we have to
reunite our country and when it comes to
that general election we have to do
something very special
we have to make british political
history
by winning a fifth election
in a row
the stakes couldn't be higher
because you know what will happen if we
are not victorious but i know that
working together all of us
we can win but it requires us to appeal
to swing voters everywhere
north and south urban and rural brexit
and remain
in wales and in scotland
and i passionately believe
that i am the person
that can deliver that victory for us
because i don't want to just ignore
nicholas sturgeon i want to take her on
and beat her
and in conclusion let me just say this
you saw me as chancellor in the pandemic
acting boldly radically
to successfully safeguard our economy
through the biggest shock it had seen in
300 years
now as your prime minister i promise you
i will apply that same grip and
radicalism to every other aspect of
government
as we build a better britain
a britain where our children can walk
safely on the streets at night
a britain where the nhs is reformed and
there for us when we need
a britain where our schools and
apprenticeships are the envy of the
world in providing opportunity
and of britain where our economy is the
most dynamic it has been with businesses
investing and innovating to create jobs
in every part of our united kingdom
but i also promise you this
perhaps more importantly
that i will give you my all
so that each and every one of you here
this evening
can always feel
enormously proud
of the conservative government that i
will be privileged to lead
so i humbly ask for your support
not just to be our next party leader but
also the next prime minister
of our great united kingdom thank you
well that's one side of the contest
you've heard but now it's time to get
the other side liz trust and her team
will get the same opportunity to make
their pitch to you so please welcome on
let's trust his team
please welcome david mandel mp
well good evening uh ladies and
gentlemen i don't think it's just
because i've appeared in vogue
the italian edition if you're interested
that i have the pleasure of introducing
liz here in perth tonight
having served as secretary of state for
scotland i know just how important it is
to have a prime minister dedicated to
delivering for every part of our united
kingdom no matter the challenge
and now more than ever we need a prime
minister who is not just an enthusiastic
unionist but a bold one too
and i am confident that that person is
liz truss
i know
how deeply and personally from her own
experience as a child of the union
growing up in paisley liz really feels
that unique connection that we have
across our united kingdom
and has shown many times that she has
the courage of her unionist convictions
to fight that corner and in particular
deliver for scotland
in my time in the cabinet liz was a very
rare thing
an ally and advocate within the treasury
repudiating the treasury's devolve and
forget orthodoxy
now as foreign secretary liz is ensuring
our department has a footprint across
the whole uk with east coal bride having
a key role
and as trade secretary she not only
brought additional departmental
resources to scotland but ended the
longest running trade dispute in history
by securing the suspension of the boeing
airbus tariffs
this was a boon for scottish business
removing those tariffs on key scottish
exports like whiskey and cashmere
and as prime minister liz is committed
to building on that success and
supporting the scotch whiskey industry
to grow its global markets
but ladies and gentlemen
as we in this auditorium know only too
well
not everyone wants scotland to succeed
as part of our united kingdom
the scottish people voted decisively to
stay part of our union
yet those scottish nationalists outside
are still desperate to re-fight that
referendum in a shameless excuse to get
away from their appalling record of
delivery
while the people of scotland just want
the constitutional wrangling to end and
for both their governments to work
together for their benefit
that's why
we need a leader like liz who will say
no to another independence referendum on
her watch
and hold the snp to account for their
failures
but who also has the steel and resolve
to be able to work with nicola sturgeon
rising above her petty nationalist games
an inevitable manufactured grievances
and liz knows securing our union is not
just about saying no to another
referendum now
it's daily demonstrating those benefits
of our union from lerwick to lockerbie
a bold unionist willing and able to take
on nicola sturgeon and the snp a record
of delivery for scotland and a
conservative agenda in downing street to
deliver growth and prosperity to our
whole country
that's why this trust should be our next
prime minister
and i know that a united conservative
party can unleash the potential of all
the people who make our country so great
to win the next election we need to
deliver deliver and deliver for the
british people
i know that our country's best days lie
ahead
i'm the candidate with a clear vision
for the future who can drive change and
get things done
as trade secretary i negotiated deals
with allies like australia and japan
creating opportunities around the world
for british business and as prime
minister
i will continue to deliver on the
opportunities of brexit
i will lead a government committed to
core conservative principles low taxes a
firm grip on spending driving great in
the economy and giving people the
opportunity to achieve anything they
want to achieve regardless of their
background
i will work day and night to lead a
party in a government that puts more
money in your pocket and secures a
better life for you and your family
i've consistently delivered when i had
said i would
and i love our country
i want the best for us all and i'm the
person to deliver that
please welcome liz trust
hi everyone it's fantastic to be here
in perth tonight
and i spent some of my most formative
years in scotland
i went to primary school in paisley the
west primary school before i moved to
leeds in england and i consider myself
to be a child of the union and to me
we're not just neighbors
we're family
and i will never ever
i will never ever let
our family be split up
i know scotland is a great country full
of enterprise and ideas from adam smith
to jk rowling
but the fact is
scotland has been let down
by nicolas sturgeon and the snp
government
they have been pursuing an agenda of
separatism
rather than dealing with the issues they
created in the scottish education system
in the nhs
and in the transport system and i know
the people of scotland deserve better
and they want better
what they want
what they want are opportunities
what they want is a
job and more opportunities in life what
they want is for their children to have
a good education in short what they want
is an aspiration nation and that is what
i will seek to deliver
as your prime minister
and as prime minister i will also have
the position of minister for the union
because that union is critical to the
success of all of us of scotland of
england of northern ireland and wales
it's one of the most successful unions
of all time
but the fact is my friends we do face
difficult economic times
we've got the war perpetrated by putin
we've got an energy crisis and we have
the aftermath of covet and we've had
several decades of low growth across the
united kingdom
so we need to do things differently
we can't just have business as usual
and i have a plan for growth
a plan for growth for the whole united
kingdom
first of all that's about unlocking the
opportunities of brexit and i will
deliver free ports here in
scotland i will make sure
that we get rid of the eu laws off our
statute books by the end of 2023
so that we can do things differently
and i will get the next generation of
trade deals that deliver even more for
fantastic industries across scotland
like the salmon industry like the
whiskey industry
like our fantastic farmers i'm proud
that as trade secretary i got the
tariffs removed by the united states
and i don't think i don't think
i actually i don't think i've ever been
more popular that is that a mazers bar
in edinburgh
a few nights after the terrorists have
been removed and i met some whiskey
distillers and they told me what it
meant for them
because what it meant for them
is more export opportunities more
ability to invest in the future and more
jobs locally and that's what i'm about
that's what i'm about this is why i
believe we need to reverse the national
insurance rise we promised we wouldn't
do it
and we are
making it harder for ordinary families
and ordinary businesses we can afford
not to do it we can still pay the debt
down after three years
i'd also have a temporary moratorium on
the green energy levy to save people
money
what we need to make sure is we have
this fantastic industry in aberdeen and
in the north sea we need to be using our
gas supplies now to help people
and of course we need to invest in
carbon capture and storage and of course
we need to invest in nuclear and of
course we need to invest in renewables
but we also need to make sure we use the
gas that we have as well
and i will also keep corporation tax low
if we raise corporation tax as is
proposed to the same level as france and
10 points higher than ireland it's going
to be harder to attract investment into
scotland wales northern ireland and
england so we need to keep our taxes low
because i fundamentally believe
we need to be on the side of people that
do the right thing
people who set up their own businesses
people who are self-employed families
who work hard those are the people we
support as conservatives
and i will back our farmers
and i will back our fishermen
we produce some fantastic produce
particularly here in scotland whether
it's scottish lamb and beef or our
fantastic seafood industry
i will make sure in 2026 when we have
full control of our waters
that we are using
our muscle to get the best possible deal
for our fishermen and you know that i'm
tough when i negotiate with europe
and we also need to be incredibly tough
standing up to vladimir putin
i'm proud
i'm proud that we were the first
european country to send weapons to
ukraine
and i as foreign secretary put the
toughest package of sanctions on russia
of any country in the world but we
cannot be complacent about our security
we need to invest in defense and that's
why i would increase defense spending to
three percent of gdp by the end of the
decade
and i've seen i've seen the type 26
being built and governed and i want to
see more of our successful defense
industry here in scotland succeed and i
will make that happen
and i will also make sure we protect and
renew our independent nuclear deterrent
i will also deal with the problem of
migration and illegal migration and the
appalling people trafficking we're
seeing
over the channel
we need to
not just implement the rwanda scheme but
we need to extend it to more countries
and i will legislate in british law to
make sure we can't be overruled by the
echr
as well as protecting freedom and
democracy overseas
we also need to make sure we protect
free speech and freedom here in the
united kingdom
i don't have any truck with the identity
politics of the left i believe that
people should be valued on the basis of
their character on their talent and
their hard work not their external
characteristics and i also believe and
i'm free to say that a woman is a woman
and i will make sure i will make sure we
protect our single sex faces including
our domestic violence shelters and i
will also stand up for the united
kingdom there are too many people who
try and talk our country down who say
the best days are behind us who are
trying to split our country up
those people are wrong
we're a great country i know traveling
the world as foreign secretary that
people have huge respect for the united
kingdom they share our values of freedom
and democracy and we need to be more
proud of that here at home and we need
to be proud to be conservatives
the reasons
for our fantastic msps and our fantastic
mps here in scotland and right across
the united kingdom is they believe in
our values
a belief in enterprise personal
responsibility hard work freedom to
choose those are the things that we
should deliver and we've got to deliver
we made massive promises in 2019 and we
have to deliver them
and i'm somebody
who doesn't take no for an answer i do
get things done
i push things through whether it's the
trade deals that people said could have
been negotiated whether it's getting the
northern ireland protocol bill through
whitehall and into parliament i get
things done and i deliver and i will
deliver for scotland
and i will deliver for the united
kingdom and i will make sure
that in 2024
we defeat
the snp and we defeat the labour party
and we win the next general election
but most of all i will make sure
that now and forever
our fantastic union goes from strength
to strength to strength
thank you very much
well that was your chance to hear
directly from both candidates in a few
minutes you'll get the chance to
directly question both candidates which
i've got to say when they're going to be
one of them's going to be prime
minister's probably much more exciting
than just listening to what they've got
to tell you but first of all
i'm going to get the chance to question
rishi sooner please welcome him back on
stage
let's start with the cost of living
crisis how could we start anywhere else
labour wants to freeze the energy cap
for the next six months scottish power
has suggested freezing it for the next
two years you're going to have to do
something like that if you win aren't
you
so i don't think that's the right
approach colin but i do completely agree
that it is the most important issue
facing
all of us
in scotland and across the united
kingdom because the anxiety that
millions are feeling right now about
what's going to happen to their energy
bills in autumn is the issue that
politicians should be focused on
during this leadership contest well
actually i announced many things as
chancellor previously you've done
nothing to ease it during this
leadership context when you've had
labour yesterday and you've had
scottish power and you're doing nothing
basically if you don't freeze the energy
cap you're going to freeze the pool
so colin what we're talking about is
what's going to happen to bills in
october right which we don't actually
know yet because that won't get
announced for another few weeks so what
i would do
is cut vat off energy bills for everyone
that will come on top of the support i
announced as chancellor that's worth
around 1
200 pounds for the most vulnerable
families but i would go further than
that because i think there are two
groups of people who will need extra
help come in the winter and that's
people on particularly low incomes and
people like pensioners those two
categories of people are ones whereas
chancellor i announced further support i
would make sure we go further if i was
prime minister and the reason is simple
is because through no fault of their own
because we are at war with russia with
sanctions
the west has decided rightly to stand up
to that aggression people are having to
pay for higher energy bills and it's
right that the government helps those
who most need our help and i think the
right way to do that is with direct
support i do not believe and this is an
important point of difference between
liam is in
liz in this contest
i don't think tax cuts are the right way
to do that now the tax cuts that lizard
are proposing
is worth about 1 700 pounds for someone
on on her income for someone working
very hard in the national living wage
it's worth about a quid a week
and for a pensioner not working
it's worth precisely zero
now i think if that's the policy that
the government adopted
millions of people
are at the risk of being tipped into
destitution i think it would be a moral
failure and i don't think the british
people would ever forgive us and as
prime minister i would not let that
happen at all
i i don't think we need to necessarily
list this the energy companies are going
to do what's in the energy companies
interests our job is to look out for
people who actually need our hearts
but we're also frustrated by the lack of
effort and work of work from your
government or the government that you
are part of just talking about a few
months ago
but you're not going to have to you're
waiting on your win
or freezing the entry price up what
about for small businesses because
they're struggling just now as well yeah
so what are you going to do well
actually
the things that i have done this year
are making a difference because
scotland particularly has a very large
hospitality sector employs hundreds of
thousands of people and the most
important way to support that industry
the tax cut that they always asked me
about was business rates and that's why
we cut business rates by 50 this year
that money was also given to the yeah
and given to the scottish government uh
to also do the same but also the
employment allowance and that's a 1 000
tax cut for small businesses to help
with their employment bills this year
that's something i did as chancellor i
grew up in a small business i talked
about my mom's pharmacy i understand the
pressures that small businesses are
under and that's why i make sure that we
will all support them that's what we do
as a party we are the party of small
business you use the word destitution
just a moment ago that's a word that in
the last few weeks has been used by
gordon brown nicholas sturgeon you're
sounding more like the opposition than
somebody wants to leave the government
well i'm sounding like someone who wants
to be prime minister at a time when
millions of people are going to see
their energy bills going up by 1 500
pounds i think it's the right thing to
do for a prime minister in those
circumstances to have a plan to address
it and start by being honest about the
scale of the challenge we face
last week at the hostings in darlington
you said that nhs spending was fine and
what we needed was reform and efficiency
how much of pay rise would you give
nurses well actually there's a devolved
matter here in england we listen to the
recommendations
we have a well-established process how
much do you if you were going to be
prime minister how much do you think
there was i would listen to the review
of the independent body and the
independent body has made a
recommendation
because the nhs is incredibly important
and you know i want to cut people's
taxes and the only way we're going to be
able to do that sustainably and
responsibly is if we are able to get a
grip of nhs spending and focus finely on
reform and efficiency of the nhs and
that's
how do we do that because that's the
important question right if everyone who
here who wants to have lower taxes
they've got to think well how can we get
more efficiency out of the biggest area
of government spending so i have a plan
to give you some sense of the things i
want to do because i want to be bold and
radical about this uh colin and i hope
this is something that the scottish
government will look at copying now i
want to tackle an issue that we all know
about for years but we haven't done
anything about and that is the issue of
missed nhs appointments right because
for so long last year 15 million
appointments were missed in the nhs
right not just at gps but at hospitals
too and that's not right it doesn't
value our doctors and our nurses and it
deprives people of the care that they
desperately need so i want to get tough
on that and this is not about making
money from charging for missed
appointments it's about changing
behavior in our countries
[Applause]
because if you can get people to cancel
appointments in advance what do we do we
create lots more healthcare people get
treated quicker the backlogs come down
faster and not a single person has had
to penny more in taxes that is a
conservative approach to reforming the
nhs
across the uk because you're not giving
them a big enough price do you think
they're worth more than five percent i
think we have an independent process
we have an independent process
you're not going to get involved even if
not he's going straight
i'm going to do i'm going to carry on
with the government's policy which is to
accept the recommendations of an
independent process that is there for a
reason and i've got a question from my
son
janice boyd from glasgow asked if you
would be prepared to live in a socially
rented property on minimum wage for a
week so you can relate to the average uk
citizen yeah so i mean i'd say i'd say
to janet look i know things are
difficult by now for many people i think
the most important thing is to help them
with their energy bills and i've got a
plan to do that and particularly focus
on the most vulnerable that's what i did
as chancellor but when our country was
plunged into
an unbelievably difficult situation a
couple of years ago
when businesses and millions of families
were watching a tv screen and not
knowing what was about to happen to them
their livelihoods their future
i
stood up and made sure that i protected
them their families their jobs their
businesses i did it in record time
those are my values and that's my track
record i'm proud of it and i would do
exactly the same as prime minister would
you ever allow another independence
referendum
as i said earlier on at a time when look
we've just spent 10 minutes talking
about the most important issue which is
the cost of living about the anxiety
that people like
talk about independence you're in
scotland would you ever allow another
independence would be great if i could
just answer the question that you posed
you rightly have focused on the cost of
living and that's because that is the
most important thing and i tell you what
like it is quite frankly it is quite
frankly barmy for politicians to be
trying to focus on a divisive and
unnecessary constitutional referendum at
a time where people are worried
of course
the union i mean i can't imagine the
circumstances in which i would like we
live in a union which is of course
thereby consent and by democracy and i
accept that but i just don't think that
anybody thinks that now or anytime in
the near future is remotely the time to
focus on this and that's not something
that i'm focused on i'm focused on
defending the union i'm focused on
demonstrating the benefit of the union
of people in scotland i'm focused on
holding the snp to account for the
failures
this is not the thing that we need to
talk about i think i'm asking you yeah
well it's the thing that i was going to
be focused on maybe people agree
well actually i think everyone in
scotland would agree that right now the
priority is focusing on the cost of
living but also what is the prospect of
other independents
they want to see their governments
scottish and uk government working
together right they want to see them
working together
so
that's emotional
they want to see you know they want to
see actually
[Music]
douglas is right because doug has been
highlighting their failures to tackle
drugs and alcohol abuse and he's got a
good plan to sort that out you know
alistair has been been there making sure
that we deliver freeport a policy i came
up with scotland right that's the kind
of thing that we should be doing and
that's what we will do with the prime
minister
reports
how did you block the acorn carbon
capture project when you were chancellor
no i i funded carbon capture and storage
with a billion pounds but not in
scotland no i funded it overall for the
united kingdom but it's not happening
it's not happening in the northeast just
now it could if there was a freeport
there do you back that would you back
back one freeport thanks to aleister and
working together with me we've backed
two free ports for scotland
so
there is an acorn cluster which is on
the reserve list for the carbon capture
and storage trade i've put a billion
pounds in as chancellor i'm always happy
to look at what we're doing to support
the scottish economy because it's
important that we do freeports are one
example but making sure that we grow our
financial services industry here is
another great example right with my
background i want to reform all the laws
that we have to make sure that we can
keep our financial services industry
incredibly competitive it's one of
scotland's economic powerhouses it's
something we can be enormously proud
about in the uk and it's another
industry alongside our fantastic energy
industry in scotland which i was proud
to champion as chancellor because again
it's something the snp government ignore
i mean we're going to get to net zero in
2050 but between now and then we do need
to use the gas that we have here at home
and that's something that i fully
support thank you
davidson's backing you but she doesn't
think you've got a chance of winning do
you still think you have because you've
already lost supporters
some of them think you have yeah yeah i
mean i i'm as you can see i'm out
fighting for the things that i believe
are right for our country i'm finding
things that i passionately believe in
and i'm going to give it everything i've
got for the last day of this contest
simple as that
open it up now
to the audience
there are people with white hoodies who
have microphones if you can wait for the
microphones come to order
and wish you so not going to take your
questions i'm going to start off maybe
taking a couple at a time so take what
hands up if you've got a question right
there's a question from a lady there
with gray hair and glasses
um and
that
okay it's platinum here sorry it's
platinum
and i'm looking for a question over
there as well lady in a stripy talk will
take you a second so take you first okay
thank you um i'm ross mccall the
conservative women's organization um
chair in scotland
um the conservatives have proven
themselves to be the party of diversity
never more so than during this
leadership race
but more still needs to be done
our party is seen by the public in a
certain way so how will you combat that
perception and use your skills to
present the new face of conservatism in
scotland
well
as as you said brilliantly this
leadership contest has highlighted the
diversity in our party and whatever
happens at the end of this leadership
contest we're going to either have our
third female prime minister
or our second ethnic minority prime
minister and it was a conservative party
that did that
so that's something for us to celebrate
but when it when it comes to how do we
appeal i i think actually uh if you
think about
all the research on on people in the
middle swing voters and broadening our
appeal by definition they're not
ideological because they're swing voters
right they're not naturally tories are
not naturally labor people and what they
want above anything else is a government
that works properly and what i want to
do is run a government that is conducted
seriously that is conducted competently
and is conducted with decency and
integrity at the heart of everything
that it does that is the change that i'm
going to bring and that's how we'll
appeal to it
okay leaving the stripey top
will you rethink your plan
to send the wretched illegal immigrants
to rwanda it is inhuman it's inhumane
and instead will you negotiate with the
french to tackle the problem where it
really begins and that's with the
illegal trap
well
so
with the greatest respect i'm gonna have
to say i disagree with you and the
reason the reason for that is simple
so look i
and i said this is really important i i
said earlier that i stand here as a
representation of our country's
compassion in welcoming people to our
shores whether it's most recently with
ukraine but before that with hong kong
syria afghanistan my family we have
always done that and we will continue to
always be that beacon of hope for people
around the world but it must be done
fairly it must be done legally and
making the rwanda policy work is an
important part of getting a grip of this
situation but it's not the only thing we
need to do i'll tell you a couple of
things we need to do to make sure that
we can do this we need to i think move
away from the echr definition of asylum
because it is too broad and it allows
many people to be here
the government were warned that rwanda
would kill political opponents before
you agreed to send them did you know
that no
the united nations
used rwanda
as a place to take refugees in
previously the united states
the united
[Applause]
so i do think that it's nations
today so you weren't aware of that
so i i was actually aware that united
nations have used rwanda specifically
as a refugee and asylum center in
previous crises because they believe
that it is a safe place okay lydia
goodbye
hi um
talking of the united nations
i don't mind you scrapping
the
human rights act as it is now
will you for fully incorporate the
united nations convention
on persons with disabilities into uk law
well madam i
i can't say 100 yes because i don't know
exactly what's contained in it but what
i can tell you
is that making sure that we have a
country a society economy that is
supportive of those with disabilities is
incredibly important to me and i'll just
give you one example of something that i
did as a junior minister to give you a
sense
now that i i had no idea until i met
families who were grappling with this
that those who are living with complex
disabilities in our society quarter of a
million of them for those people
a typical disabled
toilet is simply not sufficient because
they have to use changing benches in
hoist to help their children and because
we didn't have enough provision of those
they were forced to do things that are
incredibly undignified change their
children on the side of roads and
service stations on the floor dirty as
it would be in shops and we're not able
to have the day out that many families
would all take for granted
and they came to see me in my surgery as
a back bench mp and they said you know
we need you to help with disabled
toilets and i said what i thought
disabled toilets we have them everywhere
and they explained this thing which i
was not aware of and then as a local
government minister when i turned out
was my first job and it turned out that
building regulations were my
responsibility and what i managed to do
was change our law
so that when new buildings were built
and when large ones are retrofitted they
would make provision for changing places
toilets in all of them but i also
i also found some efficiencies in some
other budgets which are then later added
to as chancellor to massively increase
the provision of changing places toilets
across the country because i want every
family to have the dignity and the
ability to have a day out with their
children and that will give you some
sense
first of all can i say very warm welcome
to scotland thank you for coming and
when in whatever capacity i hope we'll
see an awful lot more of you
but
one simple question that requires a
short answer
will you within your first hundred days
in office signal the intention to pass
legislation that will make it illegal
for the snp government here to spend
money that is beyond their area of
devolved powers the penalty for which
would be personal liability
i see
aleister and douglas are chuckling away
at the front here so no i i mean i'm i'm
happy to go and take a look at that and
figure out what the right way right
you're doing this but your your broader
point is one i completely agree with and
it's about making sure that there is
proper accountability and scrutiny of
what the smp government is doing now
i i started to work on this as
chancellor and it needs we need to do
more because simply the mentality in
whitehall over the past decade has been
devolve and forget and it was a great
privilege to work with both douglas and
alastair and our other colleagues on
this to just lean against that and it
requires ministers to be brave because
the civil service will always want to
just devolve and forget we have to make
choices to do things differently which
is what we did with free ports with the
leveling up fund and other things to
directly do things in scotland but
holding account requires some very
practical steps and that's why i've
announced today that i want to take
forward some policies i think will make
an enormous difference to our ability to
hold them to account i want scottish
officials to be able to come to
westminster parliament to face questions
in the same way that uk ministers have
to do in scotland that's right
and crucially for something that we've
grappled with for so long i i do want to
pass a law if required to ensure that
the snp scottish government has to
produce data about public services in a
directly comparable way in the same way
that we do it across the united kingdom
[Applause]
hi there richie big fan of what you're
doing big supporter uh up here
oh where are you
all right got you right big supporter of
what you're doing what you have done in
the past as well i look after as the
accountant a lot of businesses in the
local area particularly in the
hospitality sector
we want to know what can you do to help
the still struggling hospitality sector
particularly with vat and with
corporation tax and also what can be
done to help even bigger businesses or
businesses and other sectors with the
problems they may have with corporation
tax as well as they still recover from
what kovitz did to us yeah thank you
so look the hospitality into something
that matters enormously to me and that's
why during the pandemic you saw me at
time and time again to support it and
it's not just because i like eating out
or going to the pub it's because that
industry employs two million people
across our united kingdom and typically
those people are younger they're on
lower wages they're coming off
unemployment so as a matter of social
justice it's an industry that deserves
our support now many of the other than
vat which you mentioned many of the
other direct levers are devolved which
is frustrating so whether it's business
rates for the hospitality industry
whether it's planning reform for our
high streets those things unfortunately
are not within my purview but what i am
doing is reforming alcohol duties taking
advantage of our brexit freedoms so that
next year for the first time we will
have a far cheaper rate of beer duty in
our pubs than we do in our supermarkets
so we can support that great british
institution and support our hospitality
industry that way but can i answer your
question on corporation tax because it's
really important because many of you
will have heard that i want to put up
corporation tax and you'll be sitting
there thinking hang on we thought this
guy was meant to be a tory why is he
doing that and so let me explain what
we're doing so corporation tax is going
to go up next spring as part of paying
back some of the things that we have to
do during covid and i think it's
entirely reasonable that businesses take
some of the load there but
there are three things i want you to
remember firstly the rate that the
corporation tax is going up to
is the lowest in the g7
the group of large economies that we
compete with like america canada france
italy germany
if you look at the 20 largest economies
that we compete with we'll still have
the fourth lowest rate right so this is
an internationally very low rate still
second thing you need to remember is
that it only applies to the biggest
businesses
70
of uk registered companies
will not see an increase in their rate
they'll have a small business right and
they will continue to pay the same as
they're paying now and the third and
most important thing for you to know is
that it's going to be combined with
significant new tax cuts for businesses
that are actually investing in things
and growing and businesses that are
innovating with r d to create the
products and services of the future
that's how you drive growth in a modern
economy and those bits of our tax system
are very ungenerous compared to all our
international competitors and it
explains a large part
of our lower productivity in this
country i have spent an enormous amount
of time thinking about this analyzing it
talking to businesses and based on all
my own personal experience in business
in finance and as chancellor i am 100
convinced that my corporate tax plan is
the right one for the united kingdom
because it will actually drive growth
and investment and increase productivity
and create jobs liz's plan
is the wrong one sticking with the
failed experiment of the last 10 years
whereas investment today in spite of
this low corporation tax we've had
investment today is no higher than it
was a decade ago it just hasn't worked
so instead we need to cut business taxes
on the specific things that actually
make a difference to our lives the
things that will create jobs and
productivity and that is the tax system
that i'm going to deliver for you and
trust me it will be a better one for the
united kingdom
the issue of trust and confidence in
politicians of all parties appears to be
at an all-time low particularly among
young people how would you start to
rebuild this trust and confidence
so very good question very very similar
to the lady next year who asked earlier
and i i think it's it's probably the
same answer to be honest but i think
there are some practical things we can
do very quickly right the first thing is
to restore the independent advisor on
ministerial standards and ethics it's
wrong that there isn't one and i want to
reappoint that person give them the
powers and the resources they need to
hold everyone to account because no one
should be above the rules no one should
be above the standards we expect of them
i think the second thing is it starts
with honesty and as you can see in this
election i want to be honest with the
country about the challenges we face you
can't restore trust if you're selling
people a false promise and i don't want
to do that and then the third thing to
go back to what i said to your
neighbor's answer is to make sure that
the government is run with integrity at
the heart of everything it does and that
needs to be set by the person at the top
it's as simple as that and if we can do
that then we can definitely restore
trust and we can appeal to a whole new
generation of voters
that that's why i resigned from the
government yes
we're going to try and squeeze in a
couple of questions this lady here and
then a man in the pink tie there good
evening
um i would like to ask you mentioned
accountability
and i think there's a general belief in
scotland that money sent from
westminster does not go where it should
go
have you plans to investigate where that
money is right now
and you're absolutely right and i'll
tell you i i i tell you why this was so
frustrating to me
because in the middle of the pandemic or
whenever i would be engaging with
scottish media or scott or the on the
various civil society the amount of
people that seem to think furlough had
come from nicola sturgeon right so it
just tells you what a job we have to do
and that's why some of the practical
things i talked about earlier are so
important for us to be able to follow
the money but you saw it for the first
time recently because we finally had a
chance to really go at it because i did
a spending review for the uk and which
sent four and a half billion pounds a
year of barnet to the scottish
government and then kate forbes finally
stood up and did her spending review so
we were actually able to see the choices
they made now in contrast of what we
were doing elsewhere
public spending on the nhs in scotland
is growing a far slower rate than what
it is in england
then look at the rest of the public
sector
agriculture education justice local
government
she's imposed austerity on all those
parts of public services and and yes
i have put an income tax cut in and like
that's in and i've given the scottish
government money to pass that income tax
cot on they chose not to do that so you
might scratch your head and say where's
all this money going then so they're not
giving it to the nhs they're austerity
everywhere else they're not giving the
income tax cut we found out where it's
going you know where it's going the
welfare budget in scotland is increasing
by 50
over the next five years right that is
wrong
right and we have got to be able to make
that argument we are a party that
believes in people working hard and we
want that hard work to be rewarded
that's where the priorities should be it
should be on being
cutting people's taxes not putting more
money into the welfare system and we
have got to make that argument and
that's one of the ways we're going to
beat nicolas sturgeon because our values
are the right values and they're the
values of the majority of people in our
country
would you bypass the scottish government
with some spending we already have
started that and we'll do more of it yes
so much well
i want to overcome all the opportunities
that we can to do what we've started so
whether it's with the leveling up fund
the shared prosperity fund whether it's
with now freeport so there is an ability
for us to demonstrate directly to
communities in scotland the value of the
uk government because nicola sturgeon
says she says she believes in devolution
but she doesn't really
devolution to her just means powers to
her
real devolution
the real devolution is down to the
communities and councils in scotland
that's what we're gonna
[Applause]
mr deliver um thank you very much uh for
coming to both um
lovely to speak to you today thank you
um and it would be even better to see
number ten um as a man with proper
family values um
um but my question is about the nhs
and as someone who has actually had
their life saved by the nhs who've been
like i was declared dead at one point
but i was brought back to life
um i cannot speak more highly enough
about what is probably one of the
greatest assets that this country has to
offer
um if you
when
and enter number 10 i
in charge of this country how soon will
you start reform and start bringing down
waiting times and making the nhs from
more efficiently without compromising on
the health of patients particularly that
of patients with mental health issues
yeah well first of all i'm so happy to
hear that
you you recovered properly and that is a
fantastic success story because the nhs
when it works well is it forbidden
and that's why it's important that we as
a party must be trusted with it because
we're not going to win elections if the
public don't trust us on their number
one public service priority because your
story is replicated a million folds
across the country and that's why we
need to make sure we're trusted with it
now i can be trusted with it i grew up
in an nhs family right talked about my
mum and my dad and then as chancellor i
did something incredibly difficult right
something that many of you probably
don't actually love and that's because i
created a brand new health and social
care levy to make sure that we put extra
funding in at a time of enormous strain
for the nhs because of the backlogs and
to grip social care once and for all now
i did that by the way
on a uk-wide basis i did it on a uk-wide
basis deliberately
because
the national health service is a
national service the clue is in the name
and we must never let the smp try and
make that anything less than it is it is
a unifying institution that everyone in
the united kingdom feels proud about and
i will make sure as united kingdom prime
minister that i'm supporting the nhs in
all parts of the uk and ensuring that
people everywhere especially in scotland
get the care that they need and that's
why i will not be shy about holding the
snp to account for not delivering the
things that they should because health
care is vital they've been given the
money to do it and now they've got to
get on and deliver it and we will make
sure that they
don't feed our time
to get as many questions as we can from
the audience we're already doing better
than the other hustlings have done in
terms of getting questions in so we'll
do the same when we come to liz trust
who's about to join me on stage now
[Applause]
i'm going to start where i started with
russia because it is the obvious place
to begin three-quarters of conservative
supporters backed labour's plans on
energy costs according to pulling the
times yesterday you've been left behind
on this aren't you
well first of all i think
we need to reduce taxes
because it's important people are able
to keep more of their own money and what
i think is wrong is the idea we take
money from people in taxes and then give
it back to them in benefit so what i
would do
is reverse the national insurance
increase
but also have a temporary moratorium on
the green energy levee the next thing we
should do is look at supply
and
i was in aberdeen earlier today you know
we have a fantastic oil and gas industry
in the northeast of scotland and we
should be making sure we're using those
resources to help our domestic gas
supply at this very difficult time when
people's energy bills are highest and
that should be
the best way of fixing this problem
because what i worry about is putting a
sticking plaster on this problem saying
yes we will find this extra money and
then being in the same position in six
months time and what we need to do is
make sure we're using those resources
making sure we're investing in nuclear
we're investing in renewables so we have
a long-term solution to this problem
because i'm afraid colin this problem
isn't going to go away in six months
time the appalling fact is that vladimir
putin continues to perpetrate this war
in ukraine of course i want to end it as
soon as possible of course i want to
give the ukrainians all the support we
can but what is not right is simply to
throw money at the problem without
dealing with the root cause
supporters think that the energy price
gap extending that is a good idea it's
not something you should at least be
considering
well what people
what people are concerned about and i
totally get this is energy bills and
this is a problem for consumers but it's
also a problem for businesses the
whiskey distillery i was at this morning
was telling me about their very high
energy bills so of course i understand
people's concerns and that's what being
reflected well what what i'm saying is
what we need to do is deal with the
supply issue that is the important issue
we've got to deal with now the fact is
we didn't invest in nuclear early enough
we haven't done enough to use the
resources in the north sea and make sure
the right incentives are in place and we
need to get on with that now but of
course i completely understand people
are concerned that people are struggling
this is why i think it's the wrong time
to put up taxes it's also the wrong time
to put up taxes on business because we
need businesses to invest we need
businesses to invest in new solutions to
deal with this
struggling to pay their energy costs
what help can you give businesses
particularly small and medium businesses
in scotland and across well first of all
not raising corporation tax and
reversing the national insurance
companies will help businesses
and what i want to do
is make sure we're unleashing all the
potential investment in our economy at
the moment there are some stringent eu
rules in place that we haven't got our
statute off our statute books that are
stopping that investment taking place so
business investment is very important
keeping taxes low is important fixing
the supply issue is important as well
but simply saying every problem the
answer is to tax more and spend more
government money that is not going to
resolve the underlying issue here stv
viewer tommy roger from port glasgow
asks how your tax cuts will help low
income families who are below the tax
threshold
well they will help everybody because a
growing economy means more jobs more
opportunities and more growth and
currently this country is forecast to go
into recession and we need to avoid that
because i know what how difficult a
recession is i grew up and i said this
earlier in paisley
in the 1980s in leeds
in the 1990s i know what difficult
economic times look like and we do not
want that for people this is why it's
important that we get investment that we
get businesses successful that we get
economic growth so we avoid those
consequences for all families so the
idea
well i've already said that i'll have a
temporary moratorium on the green levy
which will cut
energy bills for anything what i'm not
going to do colin here
is
write
the next chancellor's budget when we're
still in the middle of this leadership
election you know that is something i
can't do
what i can say is my first priority is
making sure the economy grows so that we
can support everybody regardless of how
well off they are the second priority is
dealing with the energy supply issue
which is a growing and pressing issue
and we need to sort it out for the long
term we can't just have a six-month
sticking plaster and of course you know
i would make sure if i was prime
minister that we help people as much as
we are able to help them but what isn't
right is simply well
as i've already said i cannot write
a future budget you're going to choose
the next chancellor if you're prime
minister so you can tell them what you
want that to be can't you
otherwise you're saying vote for me and
see what you get i i can assure you that
that is not the way
my government would work
in the i believe
[Music]
what i believe is appointing competent
people to do the job to get the job done
i don't believe in a presidential number
10.
where the prime
minister of course
colin i'd be very clear about my
strategy which is first of all keeping
taxes low and getting growth going
secondly dealing with the supply issue
and thirdly looking at you know what
else what else we can do
but
i cannot lay that out
at this stage now i've i'm foreign
secretary at the moment i'm not in
charge of the treasury or the business
department and we currently already have
a chancellor and a prime minister
carrying out those roles what i have set
out and i think i've been pretty clear
is the principles under which
my government would operate and the
principles under
you know which i would expect my
chancellor to operate but i can't lay
out full budget much as i know it'd be
great news for stv if you you know we're
able to
the guardian has um quotes from you when
you were chief secretary of the treasury
in 2019 tonight saying that what we need
from workers is more graft you stand by
that now
well what i mean i don't know what what
what you're quoting there but the point
that i've always made
is what we need in this country
is more productivity across the country
and we need more economic
don't have growth of the thing that we
don't have enough of is capital
investment and that what that is why
it's so important that we get businesses
investing whether it's in the oil and
gas industry whether it's in the whiskey
industry
because that will
we haven't done enough to be frank and i
am you know i have been openly critical
of some of our economic policies
including the national insurance rise
and
even if these policies were okay for
normal times the fact is we're not in
normal times we're in extraordinary
times and we need to be bold and we need
to do things differently and that's what
i believe people voted for in 2019 they
wanted us to unleash opportunities
across the united kingdom and that is
what i would be determined to do as
prime minister you describe yourself as
a child of the union
i've got my paisley pattern
just to say
absolutely yes
i have did you ever have a scottish
accent i had a very scottish accent
no i'm not going i am not
it might deal you to your electorate no
i want these people to vote for me so i
think i think doing a cod scottish
accent is not it's not going to work but
when i i moved from paisley to leeds
when i was 11 and i had a very strong
paisley accent at the time you said i
routinely uh got the mick taken out for
me
[Music]
you said earlier that you would never
let our family talking about the uk be
split up are you saying not now or not
ever to another independence referendum
if i am elected as prime minister
i will not allow another
we had a referendum in 2014 it was once
in a generation
once in a generation is not up in 2022.
since then we've had brexit we've had
covert which wasn't any government's
fault
well i'm coming to that but you were
about to be in our fourth prime minister
for a lot of people beyond this hall it
feels like a generation
[Applause]
what's the time scale then is there a
democratic route for scotland to decide
that it wants to change its future look
it was the democratic route
at the time
and at the time of the 2014 referendum
it was agreed by the smp that it was a
once in a generation referendum
i believe in politicians keeping their
promises and nicolas sturgeon should
keep her
[Applause]
what she should be doing rather than
agitating for another referendum
is dealing with the very real issues in
scotland and you talked about covert you
know there is a backlog in the scottish
national health service
i know that that is a priority for the
scottish people and that is what we
should be talking about and that is what
the scottish government should be
dealing with one of our stv viewers
gavin strathearn from e-school bride
says you changed your mind on brexit why
can't the people of scotland change
their minds and independence i respected
i respected the democratic will of the
people
undecided frankly and i decided to stick
with the status quo because i was
worried about this disruption disruption
didn't take place i straightaway got on
with delivering the opportunities of
brexit whether it was the trade deals
whether it was getting things done
differently on sanctions and i have done
more than most ministers in the uk
government to deliver the opportunities
in brexit and what what i am committed
to
what i'm committed to doing is
delivering for the scottish fishing
industry delivering for our farmers in
terms of new opportunities and making
sure we deliver on freeports in scotland
as well so that is what i am focused on
doing i respected the result of the
referendum the issue we've got here is
one of the parties who said that they
were going to respect the result of the
referendum who said
that it was a once-in-a-generation thing
now
you know a few years later are agitating
one of your big supporters in this
campaign jacob rees-moggs
describe douglas ross as a lightweight
do you agree with him i certainly don't
i think douglas ross is a fantastic
leader of the scottish
he is a conservative a friend of a
colleague of mine and i want to support
him to knock spots off nicola sturgeon
misled parliament and ultimately the
people over pardoning you he's right
isn't it
i don't agree
that boris johnson fled parliament
boris did a great job as prime minister
he delivered the election result he
delivered on the vaccines he's the only
world leader with a street named after
him in keeve because he backed and a
croissant as well by the way because he
backs
[Music]
he's resigned he's he's leaving the job
he's leaving the job and you know what's
done is done
and in the meantime
i think boris johnson is entitled to go
on holiday i think all of us are
entitled to go on holiday apart from
candidates in this leadership
relationship
because we're now going to move on to
our audience questions
i'm going to start at the back this time
there's a gentleman up there on the left
is there a microphone going to him
sitting next to a woman in red
near the front
yes
and if you can put your hands up when
you want me to come to you i'll try i'll
come to you next because you didn't get
in the first round gentlemen there first
hello liz thanks for coming to us in
perth this evening um in scotland we
have one functional nuclear power
station the snp would like us to believe
that they have the controlling power
over whether we can have any further
nuclear um within scotland it's clear
that we need it how do we deliver it as
a united kingdom
well i agree with you we do need nuclear
power
and i will always seek to work with the
scottish government
i want to have a constructive
relationship with the scottish
government but our priority has to be
delivering for the scottish people and
for the united kingdom and that is the
focus i will have and i'm extremely
supportive of making sure that we have
more nuclear power alongside
more gas from the north sea and more
renewables too
[Applause]
persuasion
you're not going to ignore them
you're not going to ignore them then
well i i have what i'm going to ignore
is these constant calls for a referendum
that i i will work with douglas ross in
a constructive way to help and support
the people of scotland that is my
priority
good evening it was fantastic to see you
up here one of the questions i have is
when we talk about
reversing
taxes or bringing in tax cuts
when we looked at removing the red
diesel
there and so they're not going to affect
the special local authorities we are
with our rescues trucks our equipment
and civic sites are now having to pay
full tax on on that
also the construction industry and new
house bundle for local authorities is
that something to be considered
well what i want to do is look at the
tax system overall because there are
many ways in which our tax system
doesn't work
it's too complicated it's too convoluted
and in many cases it doesn't support
business enough so areas like business
rates for example areas like duties i
think are too complicated so
i can't make any promises at this stage
but what i will do is have a thorough
review of the tax system to make it
simpler and fairer and the key principle
for me
is that people who do work hard people
who set up their own businesses people
who you know
produce food
you know fishermen these are the people
we should be supporting and we should be
making the sure the tax system doesn't
penalize them okay
good evening miss trust
both candidates are saying about helping
the pensioners and i know that very
shortly we're going to be
calculating what the increase in the
state pension is going to be
under the previous government sorry
under the previous chancellor there was
a possibility of the pensions being
increased by eight percent but he then
re-looked at the figures and decided to
increase the pensions by 3.5
are we going to use the highest level of
increase or are we just going to fudge
the figures again
i can tell you i wait i won't fudge the
figures i'm fully committed to the
triple lock which gives the highest rate
[Applause]
thanks for coming to scotland welcome to
peebles anytime
what will you do to protect scotland
from this divisive and incompetent snp
administration and preserve the union
you've sort of answered it already but i
thought i'd like to hear it from
yourself
first of all
we need to make sure we are delivering
for the people of scotland on their
priorities
growing the economy
supporting investment supporting jobs at
this very very difficult time and making
sure
that
issues like the energy supply issue are
dealt with because people will
vote for us on the basis of whether or
not we deliver and i think that is
absolutely important i am somebody who
does deliver i also want to work very
closely with douglas and his team
in hollywood because i think it's very
important that we
support
we support each other and that the
cabinet are regularly talking to the
shadow team
in the scottish parliament and we are
able to get things done in that way as
well and
that is the way
that we can take on nicola sturgeon is
by demonstrating that we're delivering
as a uk government and pointing out and
douglas and his team pointing out the
phalanx that we've seen i mean we've
seen failings on everything from ferries
to trains to roads to nuclear power
to
education you know to help you know the
list is endless but what we need to do
is show we're delivering so it can't be
just about what the snp isn't doing it
also has to be about what we are doing
and this is why
this is why
i think
things like delivering for the scotch
whiskey industry is incredibly important
and it shows what having a committed uk
government that talks to
counterparts around the world opening up
to opportunities delivers for scotland
so we need to carry on showing that
we're delivering and how that is
improving people's lives across this
country
[Applause]
thanks for coming this evening um
both candidates have spoken this evening
about supporting those that worked hard
and do the right thing
i appreciating that the bank of england
is independent from government
i one thing that i have noticed is that
the minute that interest rates go go up
by the bank of england it hits your
mortgage or loan immediately but doesn't
hit your savings account
and i'm just wondering what would your
government do
to make sure that those that are doing
the right thing and saving
feel the benefit of those interest rate
rises
the answer is there's a lot more we need
to do to drive competition
in the financial services industry and
make sure
that banks and other investors or
investment products are delivering for
people but it is a very important
principle that the bank of england
is independent and it does set interest
rates and what we need to do
is make sure the market is competitive
so customers are seeing the benefits
well it's good to see you in the fair
city
if you become prime minister
will you consider reinstating the 0.7
of gdp
that we spend on overseas aid
well the answer is that
at present
it is not economically affordable
i will see what the position is
and when we are able to afford it we
will do it and we're committed to that
under legislation but what i have done
as foreign secretary
is make sure that we're focusing our
money on humanitarian aid so we put a
lot of money into ukraine
to support
uh the people who are suffering and
struggling with food and with
accommodation and shelter
we're also putting a lot of money into
the horn of africa and what we're doing
is we're reducing the amount that we
give to the multilateral organizations
like the world bank so that we can have
more control over the spending and we
can make sure it's going to those most
in need
[Applause]
don't let me get ahead of myself okay my
question is about research and funding
something that both candidates have not
mentioned at all
in this leadership contest
so there's currently
work going on about uk's association
with the eu horizon
so what are your plans to make sure that
it's an alternative for our scientists
to be able to carry out our work
and to continue to battle
to provide
to make sure that we're ready for future
pandemics because you i know a lot of
people will agree with me science did a
lot of work to solve the problem of
covid you need to give us more funding
to do more work to carry out more
research to
cure diseases like cancer and diabetes
well
you're right we research
see a lot of researchers in the audience
today research is incredibly important
and
what i have been doing as foreign
secretary is meeting with counterparts
like the swiss
the israelis the japanese to look at
wider research networks the uk can be
part of because of course
we want to work with the eu on horizon
but they are not the only show in town
and i think it's important that we build
that wider international network we are
one of the world's best
countries for research particularly in
areas like life sciences and physical
sciences and i'm determined that we
build that wider international network
so that we are able to share our
expertise have that collaboration and
really have a global reach and that is
the opportunity for britain now we're no
longer tied
to specific schemes in the european
union we really can develop with the
best in the world
hi liz this was actually a question for
rishi but
colin kennedy
kept ignoring me so
tonight we've heard a lot about trust
and we've heard a lot about tax and yet
in government we broke election promises
and mauricio unfortunately was a serial
tax riser so can we trust trust on tax
cuts
the the answer is yes
the answer is yes i am somebody
i've i've always been a late tax
conservative
in the cabinet meeting where we discuss
the national insurance rise i was one of
a few people who spoke out against it
because i thought it was a bad idea at
the time i think it's even more
difficult now that people are facing
such hardship across the country and
also it's had a huge impact on
businesses who have to pay extra
national insurance as well so i am
completely committed to all of the tax
plans i've laid out in this campaign and
every single promise i've made as a
government minister i have delivered
whether it's on the trade deals whether
it's on dealing with the issue on the
northern ireland protocol whether it's
on sorting out the sanctions and i will
sort out our taxes
well now now you're asking for even more
what i've said what uh you see what i've
said is there will be an overall review
of our tax system and it is too
complicated you know we have seen a lot
of drift in terms of the levels of
allowances we will look at that but what
i want to make sure
is that we have a very clear economic
plan that grows the economy because
ultimately this country is going to be
successful when we get business going we
back business we see a faster growing
private sector than the public sector
that's what i want to achieve
hi hi liz i'm just
i'm from northern ireland was brought up
there i've been living on the the
mainland now for 20 years i was home the
other week and all my friends and family
would like to know
are you going to get
sinn fein and the dup
and the government to get things done
the answer is yes
but we do need to resolve the issue with
the northern ireland protocol
because at the moment what
what the protocol is causing is it's
causing
a feeling of
unfairness between the two communities
in northern ireland because it is very
hard and people i know there are
scottish businesses who've stopped
sending goods to northern ireland
because of the bureaucracy and the
paperwork so we need to sort that out we
need to create the green and the red
channel and we also need to make sure
that the people of northern ireland are
able to benefit from the same tax rates
as the people of great britain
it's understandable that people feel
they're not being treated as part of the
united kingdom because of the way the
northern ireland protocol is operating
so this is why the protocol bill is
important i have been in talks with the
dup uh and they are supporting the
northern ireland protocol bill and i
expect to see things happening and the
executive reforming
i'm going to try and squeeze two more in
there's a gentleman up the back and then
there's a lady in the middle
uh good evening miss truss
you have talked a lot about
the role of fracking could play in
addressing the energy crisis
in light of the scottish government's
position on fracking how would you as
prime minister persuade the snp green
scottish government to change their mind
it's a similar question to the uh to the
nuclear question i do think
the scottish you know the snp green
government is a
on one hand they're saying people should
have lower energy bills so than the
other hand they're refusing to back
anything
that will actually help deliver uh low
energy bills
we can persuade them
that actually these are important ways
of transitioning to net zero but what we
can't do when we're achieving net zero
is to hammer consumers and hammer
businesses in scotland because
ultimately what it will mean is less
revenue into the exchequer and less you
know let fewer opportunities for the
people of scotland so i will make that
case leave you there with a brief
question isn't it it is a brief question
isn't it good evening i think that in
the early stages of this leadership
election rishi
had more parliamentary support than you
did will you if you become the next
prime minister will you seek to unite
the party by including rishi and some of
his leading colleagues in your cabinet
in leading
you and positions
i don't know if you're following but i i
have gained quite a few parliamentary
supporters in recent days
including and i don't know including 11
members of the whips office who've come
out in support of me today but it is
important that we unite the conservative
party we're all conservatives we all
want to beat nicola sturgeon we all want
to beat kierstarma and we all want to
make sure conservatives win here in
scotland as well as right across the
united kingdom so
i will want to appoint a cabinet
of all of the best talents from right
across the conservative party
including rishi sunak if i am successful
in this leadership election
well that's pretty much issue a lot i've
got as many questions as i possibly
could from sdv viewers crucially from
you in the audience tonight if you'd
show once again your appreciation to
both candidates please
so you're going home to vote some of you
might even be voting on your phones well
that was going on for all we know but
thank you all for taking part thank you
all for your questions sorry if we
didn't get them all in but there was a
limited space and a limited time thank
you for our std viewers for watching
online and watch out for the result on
september the 5th thank you
thank you
you